[Musica]
e oggi speciale di natale e capodanno
per fare tutto certo piccole feste cioè
andremo a fare lo slime della ruota con
il calendario della volta e come per
l'intensa e frane missione box e il
caffè ligura tempo io un albero di
natale in testa
io so metà babbo natale piazza io
persistono timbo viola che la di grosso
allora con funzione in pratica la rotta
deciderà o alle piste di fox che dovremo
andare a prendere o con gli occhi chiusi
o dovremmo scegliere noi e disperanti
perché dovremmo aprire in alcune caselle
possiamo aprire fino a 3 i numeri del
calendario quindi vediamo se saremo
fortunati in più tutte le cose che sono
dentro nell'essere box del genere sono
tutte a tema natale tema feste quindi
uscirà on line tema western con il
problema però quali sono i colori di
natale il verde rosso
guarda caso verde infatti ben il 68
e all'umiliazione con la ruota
consigliate sì quali fare nei commenti
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
video tutto su calcio e alla fine di
essere il sondaggio in cui dovrete
votare seguito io possa giudicare i bar
della bellezza dello slide inizia certo
organizzato che ha fatto che io vediamo
un pò la rosa e cosa si riserva oggi 16
più 24 giugno c'è un primo colpo mentre
tra cui il 24 e il numero più grande 4
inizia dal numero 7 eccolo il pacco
regalo
scrivo per i grassi 20 di verde mediamo
bene o male allora il numero 7 sono
brillantini color giallo colore 16 ecco
qua è un altro regalino mi ha detto che
adesso sono twitter bianchi per l'altro
24 che c'è la più grande e più bello
vediamo a meno che non sia un bello
scherzetto nel 24esimo bello scherzo
detto qualcosa col e trasparente più
questo allora questo piano non andrò
mettiamo così nello slang decorazione
tagliare affettive ed è una decorazione
natalizia bellissima fortunata più moto
diventa credibile cosa
[Musica]
io ho veramente
no sinistri box più 23 ma devi chiudere
gli occhi di scegliere una vista il box
va bene gli occhi ma posso primo a
prendere il numero e poi dopo vogliamo a
quella neo mister box nei 23
vediamo
ecco tu e vitale inizia a rompere tutto
il calendario con quelle vite qatar non
posso dire è che fortuna
preparate bene
ok puoi dare un disoccupato
[Musica]
per questo 3 qual è l'ultima stima
ok aspetta lasciato queste scatoline con
le foglie e veniamo io ho scelto quello
che stava sotto ma con il mito quello
che cosa si bambini che dobbiamo ai
tanti natale con questi colori nathalie
mi piace mi piace mi piace e avendo
questo puoi scegliere tutto
chissà che uscirà la splendida tale più
bello il mio
vedremo ma io cosa devo mettere corrotta
aver avuto problemi a non passare mai
dimentico l'angolo di natale dal 1 di
natale con le palline di uno stupendo ed
è bellissimo news line non sappiamo già
che vincerò vorrei ancora privi di
ingredienti che bell uno squarcio stata
fortunatissima perché mi è capitata
questa colla fly non me lo avete
regalato a voi agli incontri non ho mai
visto una colla con scritto proprio
slide sopra comunque abbiamo provarla
vediamo un po come liquida
beh forse se super trasparente magari lo
slime bianchi bellissimi live di natale
onorata brillante e poi l'inter gialli
che sempre coperti bartolini qualitalia
ritagliate dei pezzi della decorazione
con carini se premuta i fiorellini come
diventerà un aeronave vari dorato e me
tocca a me no pochi illusi calendario
che 19 quindi prima casella occhi chiusi
e poi devo aprire il 19 ma quale casella
sceglie il numero 8 ok per 19 e allora
28 e un
come si chiama bersani e casini sono dei
campanili che sono ci sono dei delle
stelle delle reti occhetti di neander
celesti e di delle renne e che pare che
la mia musica natale
l'america non vedere meglio con questo
campo nei lidi colora altro perché
el'asinello tema la reina sull'asinello
si sa se non sapevo se si fa dentro
allora ci sono altri peter bianchi non
so perché il piatto che forse luiten
questo challenge
poi ci sono certificare tutto
guardatela che stephen a
[Musica]
theodore dici cose così così e così
ok italiano già definitivamente del
prete glitter verdi vediamo infatti ma
non si vedranno che le coperte il suo
slime la bird è stato ancora più bello
cos'è allora metto per primo questi
twitter bianchi che mi sono capitati che
faranno un po perfetto né per non sono
molto brillanti queste però poi metto
cose che mi sono capitate che sono
carinissimi sembra che pure il plan de
rose e nemmeno dei fiocchi di neve si e
poi ho avuto un sacco di cose allora qua
ci sono altre nazioni questi sono i
campanelli quando questi sono i dolci
un'idea di come saranno i campanellini
nella lotta ma attenzione sono anche
verdi campanellini sono aperte lì quindi
un po di verde ce l'ho anch'io poco però
che strano vista come saranno dell'hiv
questi campanellini porta bene di quel
che appare libero la reazione
beh vediamo una volta telo attiviamo
come di vendola non avranno più una
volta
nelle mense un pandoro è un cross ma
dopo un fattore cruciale siamo invece è
tutto qui ha beccato la maledizione di
rifiuti abbiamo sia le berline allora
mettiamo prima di terni per rivivere
sarà nicola di natale solo un albero lo
slime albero di natale
no ci sono anche le decorazioni rosse
gialle con cui si vedono mai sinistro
piano e nuovi giochi tennis e chi perde
e chiese subito febbo a chi ha fatto 4 a
13 li abbiamo già per noi questo live
che sarebbe un verde
ben il 35 di essere una cosa diversa
durante il campus a speriamo noi che
riesce gialloblù meglio come farebbero
meglio sul mio che è albero di natale al
piano diventare una pallina rossa
diventa una bisogna dall'agesc rientro
se vuoi di dante e lido in verde manca
di abbiamo subi'to ben figura bene
allora atto non si deve niente da fare
io che poi proprio scegliere io scelgo
lotto non la gente comune allora che il
gatto anche nelle fila
[Applauso]
però queste superstrada di nervi sarà la
nostra perla è tantissimo ma chissà
movimento lo slide con questa che bello
vabbè ma chiesto io sono delle perline
bianco dai almeno sono bianche non sono
più belli anche al rosso gonfiare il
meno dire un po di colore
io quest'anno avevo finta e stranissimo
perché diversa dalla solita neve finta
ebeti e perline e con le bravi linee e
adesso chiederò tutorial di vedermi
oddio una gradita alla mente stranissimo
è diventato una granita alla menta e
devo dire che ora sembra di più un
albero no sembra un tipo le foglie
dell'albero colore verde non era sciolta
una gravina di puglia fare bene dai
affetto e carino e originale
infine bellissimo nella verde a mora del
colore sfigato banche cavolo fino
all'ultimo proprio sul predetto sito
pocket ricordiamo che poi si sta
mischiando un po con il giallo per
sull'intero anno poi osceno blu ed io
dico di no perché ci sono solo colori di
natale quindi potrebbe camminare il
rosso e blu verde rosso e giallo forza
le palline figlio tale
bene vediamo carino dai adesso ha un po
più di colore un po più natalizio 16 e
15 6
e qua vediamo cupa giusta luce tutte le
cose belle almeno non ci crederà lato
c'è anche il verde perché sono tutti i
colori natalizi rosso bianco e nero e
vende ormai vite sempre una bella
società da trovare prove che l'inter è
sempre l'inter viola e glitter argento
meno male almeno questi biglietti
[Musica]
tokyo 21 21 se si ok allora l'ho sentito
l'altro allora io scelgo 18 apertura
ok andare peggio
sono belli questi giorni sul mio slam
andranno molto bene sono decorazioni
durante ha aperto cos'è ma con lo stesso
pero sono color argento
che coincidenza ma meglio ai colori ma
questo è tanto lo so che se l'è attivo
molto applicate allora ragazzi sono
gialli e rossi
e questi sono solo argento fitto
nevischio tutti insieme nella piazza di
cisterne o no i primi nove mesi lo slime
che è diventato siano consistenza
stranissima bene e quella neve finta che
mi ha rovinato con il live ma la rapina
bello colorato sempre proprio un albero
di natale ma e mancano di catan attimo
vediamo il mio invece questi maledetti
pon pon verdi rossi bianchi verdi neri
rossi
si stanno malissimo questa che brutto
questo caso gigante scarafaggio un
favore viola un po più di colore e poi
questi sono bellissimi perché sono al
100 ma sono un po più grandi guarda
diventati questo scarafaggio fa bene
però è un po un miscuglio di forse
questa ormai è diventato più rosso
natalizio 1 10 al rotolamento 100k che
fortuna di little color bronzo piano
piano fermo 9 18 18 ho scelto prima non
vedo qua quindi africa ma che fortuna ho
provato a chiamare rossi
abbiamo stata solo una vettura se stessa
prima di metterle rigiriamo
l'impressione che i tre il topino ieri
momenti perdiamo a vita sono capitati a
me è capitato il verde sarebbero le
stesse l'expo tante le stesse
decorazioni che sono capiti di abitare
in the colori ad essere capitati in
verde ultima tra l'altro lo educa
prossimo però si metterà poi così magari
diventare la sala del milan abbiano idee
le guarda
[Musica]
scegli tu più perfido al 22 avevo già
preso di sassi quindi puoi scegliere low
price è rimasto c'è rimasto il 2 il 20
il 11 e il 17 mag
quale preferite vediamo insieme
guardando il calendario a chi oggi a
questi si sono disputate sono miste
anche agli altri questo questi qualche
io dono tanto che c'erano tantissimi
temi sono uscite prima e queste le
capore lire dopo così vediamo gli rossi
e fortunato che si guarda che bello sarà
superclan c è ma li perdono a tutti
quando soprattutto questo
perché volevi remerebbe colorate come
capitoni di natale incorporate gira il
film non fa più rumore aprile sono
riempite di glitter bronzo che
vincolerebbe sembra più il tronco di
nata fatta dilatata prime perché marrone
poi devo mettere purtroppo deve
dimettere tutti questi gli interventi
glitter
slittano di vietarlo speriamo che
passano un bell'aspetto almeno oggi c'e
un sacco di roba nel mio slide ora metto
il colorante rosso speriamo che diventi
di un bel colore dio ma 9 tira un bel
tronco di natale viene 2 essere vediamo
e incredibile come il colore può
cambiare tutto lo slime hai un po più
belli d'italia renzo rosso speriamo che
rimanga così pochi costumi e sport
[Musica]
so che posso scegliere io e poi questo
film argentino ma allora a scoprirlo
strumenti molto fortunata io posso aver
detto tutto rossi effetti e poi ricevuto
una busta di boxe all'altro perché sto
per carino oppure quello lì perché dai
vestiti di crisi perchè potrebbero
studiare time per sempre
ho fatto una non perfetta
[Musica]
21 21
abbiamo già aperto quindi puoi scegliere
tutto è rimasto solamente lui si aspetta
almeno fortuna o non utilizzato adesso
allora su twitter neri sono urgenza e
poi ci sono le campane delle reti che in
ogni genere mandarà campanino quali sono
i nomi delle rende vediamo chi lo scrive
prima nei commenti
uno era rudolf che sono rimaste solo due
viste di boxe quindi me si gira lo rosa
sceglieremo paper vediamo se insomma
mettersi d'accordo quindi per l'ultimo
ma in assoluto viviamo posso anche
sventrare la adesso
e così su curioni e bianchi i coriandoli
a natale con tasti purtroppo la fifa sia
mattina e allora quale chiesto al mio
letto mi sono spesso nato questa maniera
questa la molla che arrivava con fettine
e arrivi ancora adesso da un ruolo
a me non piace
sprint a quella strana quella che
passeggiata prima vitale e su è la
novità è quella ricchezza mentre la
carne e altri alimenti gli altri clienti
cosa ad aprire la mia ultima visto i box
da installare la mia il bello siamo
pronti a guardare il bene che questa
parlando di pare che ci sia la giusta
pensavo essendo verde non ci sarebbe
il mercatino offerti dai omesso dalla
felpa verde uscito lo slide verde
decreteranno dopo quando diventerà
marrone ma ora mettiamo il coriandolo di
capitale è veramente consumi grazie
incredibile questa rischia di diventare
il coriandolo recentissimo tutti
scomparsi ne sono più bene meglio così
poi questa niente finca maledette quando
raggiungerà tutti stessa con lo slime e
organi ma almeno non riuscita a farlo di
un colore bellissimo natalizio rossa o
mi mettono le mode adesso che gilberto
voglio vedere
vediamo vediamo di che marrone diventata
mamma forse lo scrisse io volevo sembra
ospiti natale scomparso tutto dai non è
verdissima verrà così le fa il mio
bellissimo show live di meta learning
slime aldo di natale si è già
solidificato allora li mettiamo prima i
glitter allora co2 di linda belli questi
glitter bellissimi
in tanti poi mettiamo gli altri glitter
argentati che fortuna e poi dovete fare
di lei e altri campanilistica
prenderebbe e poi l'ultimo è benedetta
la meravigliosa deve filtro che io amo
tanto benissimo mi piace un sacco e non
è vero senza ottenere questo slize giro
via il tempo bello di ruolo
sottoscrivere di natale l'ho già attivo
praticamente andiamo ad attivare i
nostri me poi possono vedere potrete
votare chiamenti timore di granita alla
menta gravità questo albero di natale
ecco qua il lumicino slime allora alla
fine è uscito una sorta di bertolino
celestino mercato io volevo slime rosso
comunque ha un sacco di decorazioni
dentro come potete vedere è abbastanza è
scrivibile non è detto
fortunatamente non la rovina come molto
si vede qua il punto mezzi che sembrano
ricordatevi poi che siamo un pochino
è un pò natalizio ma non tantissimo non
è proprio super natalizio un po sì dai
quindi se molto gli date da 1 a 10
perfette persone stand airline grazie ai
gol di di natale che stanno si schieri
do tantissimo il carlino molto colorato
allora colore verde dell'albero di
natale c'è sicuramente la neve finta
sull'albero di natale acer cure e tutte
le decorazioni natalizie come
campanellini le palline e tutti i colori
ci sono anche quindi io direi che vinco
io ti amo rumori bellissime i rumori non
ci sono scaltri da zero nella pelle che
bello almeno siamo a natale l'albero di
natale
beh che dire allora che stai facendo
mila su quanto da casa oppure chiama
allora chi votate
be nice
come deve attrezzare gli orafi la somma
4 metri e su cui cliccare cliccate
quella che preferite